I got expelled from preschool the only
person in the history I just wouldn't
have it I wanted to go home I tried to
escape I did escape and I wanted to go
home I would just scream and cry until
my mom came to pick me up I made it
through kindergarten but it was like
every day after school I would cry
waiting for my mom to come pick me up
because I wanted to go home so bad I
just did not want to be there I hated it
and I don't know to this day like why
kids weren't particularly mean to me I
actually had friends I was weird but it
wasn't like I was bullied like I mean I
was kind of picked on because I was the
skinny Runner kid it was more just like
people Josh use all the time yeah but I
hated it I hated being confined I hated
being restrained I just always felt like
I could go faster like I felt like very
restricted and I don't mean that in some
conceited way like oh I'm smarter than
people that's not even it I just felt
this is not a good use of my time